toujours pour terminer la sortie du
dernier album de titeuf ce héros de
bande dessinée à la houppette un
phénoménal succès d'édition 2 millions
d'exemplaires mis en place il y à bien
une petite of magna marie-hélène bono
mathieu dreujou l'heure de la sortie
avant la rentrée
la sortie du dixième album titeuf tirage
2 millions d'exemplaires
un événement tant attendu par les
enfants que certains le lis sur place
avant de l'acheter et je voulais la voir
le 24 quand nortel va bien je pourrais
pas faire ce que je marquerai sur titres
c'est quoi il fait plein de bêtises
chez les ados ce qu'on préfère c'est son
vocabulaire j'm'en le spip ou chao ou
nettement gaza titeuf à 10 ans il
représente 11 millions d'exemplaires
vendus
le tirage du top 10 c'est plus de cinq
fois celui d'un prix goncourt
mais ne parlez pas d'argent a à z je
suis super content lettres échangées par
l'oncle ambre enfin c'est pas un peu
vertigineux quand même je ne sais pas de
la gamme de relever rssi vertige aussi
du côté des produits dérivés 2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires par an
bientôt un jeu vidéo
le budget communication de l'éditeur
pour le dernier album 1 millions d'euros
voulait vraiment que je parle finances
alors que moi je vous parlais du contenu
du rapport affectif vous avez alterné
des enfants voyez la réaction aux actes
en deux alors ne parlons plus d'argent
pour ses 10 ans titeuf a eu un super
cadeau un livre dans lequel les plus
grands dessinateurs l'on croque et à
leur manière